[Music]
award-winning chef christina tozi
revealed her secret to baking in a
recent ted talk
now as a kid breaking the rules usually
only got us in trouble right
but as adults
it's a different story
breaking the rules pushing boundaries
challenging the norm
asking why why not
it does something to us
it
shakes us from sleepwalking
and it makes space
for magic to sneak in
yeah speaking of magic toesie is the
owner of the famed milk bar the national
bakery chain is known for treats like
the naked layer cake birthday truffles
in the compost cookie oh we love it fast
company just named it one of the world's
most innovative companies for 2022. tosi
is also the host of the netflix series
bake squad where expert bakers compete
to create the next level desserts
here
she is here with her new book and it's
dessert can save the world she writes
about her path to success and how sweet
treats can connect us all christina
tozie is here she joins us right now
first on cbs mornings how are you doing
good morning i'm sorry i'm happy to be
with both of you and to feed you just a
little dessert okay now before the
responsible stuff yeah let's get to the
interview first before we dive in the
desserts now your book is all about the
power of dessert and in it you reveal
your personal mantra which is
just bake the cake you know what are we
waiting for it's a little bit of we put
things off we're waiting when it comes
to dessert we wait for the big moments
the big celebrations the supposed to
moments
and i'm just a believer in life of like
just start start now do it just because
if you wait until things are perfect
till the supposed to
you've lost so many more opportunities
to bring a moment to spark something in
a day to bring goodness into the world
we just need more excuses well you also
say dessert face it you said nobody
really needs dessert i disagree with you
about that but you said dessert just
brings you such joy and you believe
dessert can change the world it's more
than just the eggs the flour and the
sugar what do you mean by that it's the
spirit it's the emotion the title of the
book is meant to be the entire book is
meant to be a rally call a reminder of
but if we feel joy ourselves we will
give joy to others it's the pay it
forward mentality right dessert for me
baking
exploring creativity creating something
does something for me the dessert
connects me to who i'm baking for who i
feed who i give it away to the power
that the dessert can do maybe it's for a
bake sale whatever it is and those
things those tiny small seeming things
they spark they spark they create um
they create momentum they spark a
revolution they have this power
but normally when we look at a cake we
go that's for my birthday i'm gonna hold
off once one day every 365 days i'm not
okay
i'm not okay with that we need more of
you can have cake whenever you want you
can and dessert for me is
the way that i do it but dessert can
also be a metaphor everyone has their
version of dessert their version of joy
of goodness that does these things and
we need more of that now you face some
hurdles you write about not taking no
for an answer and you write about
something called the milk bar sweat down
what is that i like this the milk bar
sweatdown i was raised by these fierce
heroic matriarchs and they were like
you be you you're going to show up in
your chuck taylors you're going to show
you show up as you are
people are going to judge you but you
want to know what you don't conform to
the way people see you you just keep on
your path you just bake the cake you
keep on your path and when they start to
tell you no or you're too this or not
enough that or whatever it is you just
sweat them down and you do that with a
smile and just every single day just the
relentless you're gonna be my partner in
saying yes you just don't know it yet
and that's how i've grown milk bar over
the past 13 14 years i mean no one
thinks a bakery is supposed to be able
to do these things or win these awards
and we like the underdog mentality
that's who we are but in order to really
get to where you need to go in life you
have to just be unrelenting and hearing
the word no and figure out how to get
someone's no into a yes and when you
look at it now backwards christine it's
on so i say game on so you don't take no
for an
answer honestly i flipped the script
that's how you flip the script as a kid
say i like your last chapter milkshakes
can perform miracles you said that was
the hardest one to write you tell a very
sweet story about walking your dog
butter but you said milk what do you
mean milkshakes are the just say yes
what do you mean milkshakes are
milkshakes can perform miracles there
are so many stories within that but it's
basically the this seemingly simple you
have something and you give it away to
someone else at a moment that is
seemingly normal
it does something
giving someone something that is yours
away because they seem like they need it
or they want it that particular time it
connects you this is this is the power
of dessert in all of its wonder and
glory but specifically now when we're
going
i need a miracle today to get through
the day i need a miracle to be able to
see into the future reading your book
i'm such a i'm so triggered by things
nine o'clock at night i was reading this
i went to cvs got some chocolate ice
cream
made myself a milkshake please show the
picture i was so proud of myself
i made myself a milkshake
and and put a banana in it okay okay
because it's responsible and put a
little caramel ice cream in it pure joy
on guilt so there you go that's right
you innovate at nine o'clock at night i
did that christina look what you did
come on christina there's so many sweet
layers to this book no pun intended but
what do you want people to take away
i want people to take away that
to get to where
you want to be in a day in a moment in
your life in your journey you actually
have everything you need in you you just
need more reminders of how to pull it
out that you are in control when you're
in in
the driver's seat you just have to
sort of flip the script ditch the recipe
as one of the other chapters and sweat
them down
51 you give us moments places we should
go pete's hamburgers in wisconsin i want
to go there and the strawberry doughnut
place i want to go there glendora
california that's right i want to go
christina thank you so much thank you
christina desserts can save the world
goes on sale today wherever you like to
buy your books so go out and get one